[Music]  focus right here  [Applause]  you're me  [Music]  food at home a house cleaned  and discretion above all else  boys and their toys at least we know  they're getting work done  [Music]  welcome to the victory project we're all  here because we believe in the mission  what are we doing changing the world  what are we doing changing the world  that's right  what do you think  they're really doing out there  what do you mean  the one thing they ask of us is to stay  here  [Music]  where it's safe  do you even know what the victory  project actually is have you ever asked  do you  please  what's actually happening stop it alice  no  jack  it's okay  i'm curious to hear where she's going  with this  i need you to listen to me  [Music]  you're lying about everything  we are not going backwards we're pushing  forward  everyone is acting like i'm crazy  and i'm not crazy  [Music]  our life  together i could lose this  i don't trust  [Music]  so  [Music]  you